hello everyone welcome back to the fetal
World Cup 2019 it's round 2 point 1 and
it's a very nice game between shot her
mama dr andrew stone custom john of a
lot we have requested it already and for
good reasons as it is a wonderful game
so thank you all for that
without further ado let's just check it
out
so mama door with the white pieces opens
with d4 with Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight
to f3 and of course you all know where
this is going d5 we have the Queens
gambit the client Bishop to g5 and now D
captures on c4 with E for preparing to
recapture on c4 and here b5 one of the
at one of the lines where it's actually
okay to defend your c4 pawn with a for
now attacking the b5 pawn c6 defending
and now Knight to c3 we have Queen to b6
and here in 2018 the most-played move
for example with Bishop captures on f6
but in 2019 new poison has been found
with Bishop to e2 so a few games in 2019
have followed the dis exact exact same
path we have Knight B to d7 and now d5
and there is one game for example where
black got a good game but in the end
white hole for one where b4 was played
it was last year
Alexander area ideas answer vs Latimer
14 in the Margaret scheme Memorial
Tournament where one were a white one a
very nice game even though b4 is is a
fine move for black but here with he
captures on d5 and eek a person d5 is a
new move in the position so already as
of move 9 very very exciting chess with
ECAP Tristan b5 and only now before
going after the night D captures and c6
now threatening to capture here with
Chuck so Queen captures on c6 and now
Knight to b5
and here in Bishop to c5 black is ready
to castle this night for the moment
doesn't have any threats there with
castles by white and here black could
have castled which probably is a good
idea but the move playing the game is
also fine he played Bishop Toby
seven putting pressure here on Dungey -
and now you also might have some ideas
of castling queenside it's hard to say
why why castles wasn't played before but
okay Nightbeat d4 attacking the Queen
here trying to get black to give up his
dark squared bishop but Queen to d5 and
here rook to c1 white is now ready to
recapture the gambit is pawn black
decides he will play c3 with be captures
and c3b captures on c3 and now not
recapturing with the rook which is also
fine but the bishop captures on f6 is
much stronger freeing this diagonal for
the light square bishop with Knight
captures on f6 and now Bishop to b5
check which is very important as now
trying to block check for example Knight
back to thee seven just loses the rook
to e1 check and now you have to go here
otherwise you lose the night you have to
defend it and now just the rook captures
on c3 and the black King in the line of
fire of whites heavy of the artillery I
will just not be able to survive this
rope is coming to d3 and that's just
game over so after Bishop to b5 check
with King to f8 by Kasim John off and
the now comes rook captures on c3 just
grabbing that pawn now also the rook
enjoin on d3 and the black still has to
restart what to do with looking and also
how will you get your h8 rook into the
game black of course wants to do it as
soon as possible we have g6 preparing to
Castle artificially and now Bishop back
to c4 pushing the Queen back we have
Queen to d6 and the now comes rook to d3
and here black has a couple of a couple
of ideas how to go about this position
but going King g6 right away King g7
right away it doesn't really work you do
want to do it as soon as possible but
rook to d3 was played to prevent this
now Knight a5 check will either win the
Queen or you will grab the night and
then just the rook captures and b6 picks
up the Queen Bishop character screen
captures and black is lost here
so after rook the d3 first Queen to f4
getting the Queen out of the way but now
mama Dara starts a very fine attack
there was also a different line possible
a momager
Queen to a-1 grabbing hold of this
longest diagonal on the board at the
moment that is free but also possible
was g3 attacking the Queen and after the
Queen moves and now Queen to b3 going
after the f7 pawn so that was also one
of the possibilities for example if you
go Bishop captures an f3 you get nice
captures and now after King g7 you go
Knights thief I would a triple attack on
the f7 pawn also the Queen is under
attack and the black would not have a
very nice game here but okay I'm a meter
of played Queen to a-1 he has a
different plan with King the g7 and now
mama drf plays a very nice idea I just
want to point out that there are a
couple of moves that are very nice here
for example Knights the e6 check Forks
the king and queen and then you get F
captures and rook to d7 check if you go
here black is lost you have to go to h6
now you recapture on b7
the game continues white is a little bit
better because black king is on h6 but
the game continues
however mama deriv started a different
attack a different brilliant attack and
for this attack we will grant mama your
of a morphe head so there it is
mom you're off now has a morphe head and
he plays Bishop captures on f7
so you don't really have a better move
other than to recapture the bishop for
example if you try removing some of the
attackers the the f7 pawn is going so d7
square is now free for the night you
will just lose your queen
so King captures Bishop is in fact the
best the best you have here so King
captures Bishop was played and now
Knight to e2 as usual the strongest move
is a move with the knight back the Queen
is under attack we have Queen the f5
attacking the rook and now the nightmare
continues Knights the g3 madera now
offers the rook because if you capture
the Ruby deny key five checks the King
and traps the well wins the Queen so
after Knight to g3 Queen back to f4 and
now tonight's the e5 check the Queen
nicely protected the night from a1 and
here King the g7 is best for black even
though it's hard to do this put your
King on this diagonal that the Queen
occupies for example night
these seven comes with an attack on the
knight on the bishop but still after
Bishop to e7 you could attack it rook e1
rook fe8 black could continue this game
however black didn't like this King to
g7 move black played boldly King to east
six and now this this doesn't move but
this doesn't work but feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out why this
bold idea doesn't work while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent Punisher of bold
ideas that don't work and for those of
you who just wanna enjoy the show quint
a to check you have to invite the king
even further down the board that's how
it's done interest for example if King
captures on e5 then mama dear I've had
rook to e1 planned with check and now
the King has no squares Knight cars at
five this is covered by the Queen this
is covered by the rook you have to block
it for example 94 now you get Queen to
be to check and here you're just lost
for example you move the King looked f3
now forcing the Queen to move back you
can go to f6 as the knight is pinned
from the rook here if the Queen protects
the f6 square for example Queen g5
you're just gonna pick up the Bishop on
b7 King Queen captures here and there's
nothing to do here there is now a triple
attack on this night here you cannot
defend that you are completely lost
so Queen to a2 very deadly moved by mr.
Murphy mamedyarov
so black has to block Bishop to d5 but
more female media of continues the
attack rook captures on d5 and okay the
d5 square is protected so custom jonov
captures it with Knight captures on d5
and now another excellent move with the
knight back Knight to b3 attacking the
bishop the Queen for threatening some
nice discoveries so Queen to d4
defending the bishop what else will he
do and now yet another move with the
knight back Knight to e2 as you can see
the nightmare just it keeps going now
again you cannot capture the night and
night at four picks of the Queen once
again because the knight is pinned you
cannot recapture with with this Knight
so it's not possible
Queen to g4 was played hoping
at least grab a breath of fresh air
maybe after night captures on c5 and
King moves but mama DRF continues in
great style he plays Knight II can night
eat f4 check checks the king and now
there's a double attack against the
night here again the knight cannot
capture king to f6 and here mama D are
just played
I mean mister more familiar of play
Knight captures on d5 with check and it
was in this position that a roost on
custom John of resigned the game as
there is nothing more to do here
once you react the check King g7 you are
also losing the bishop here and ok you
do have you could say that white only
has two nights for a rook but that's
more than enough with with the King wide
open and black is not interested in
playing this game in any longer
yeah the very nice game one of the nicer
game so thank you all for suggesting it
really a really a nightmare on the board
so I do hope you enjoyed it I would like
to think Santosh Kumar
Saravanan for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video serie thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World Cup
checking up on your lovely suggestions
such as this one and we will have a
conclusion to the capablanca saga at
some point so I think y'all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your weekend